they our focus today is going to be on
business models and what I'm going to do
is start by introducing the topic in a
few minutes and then we turn it over to
Howard and Andre who are two great
business model innovators who can tell
us about some of the developments in the
area so just as we have a blueprint for
a building that helps us structure and
plan the construction effort the
business model is a structured model
that describes how a venture will create
and deliver value with customers in how
it will extract some of that value for
itself
in a construction project we try to
stick to the plan with manual
Corrections along the way in contrast a
new venture development we keep
iterating and experimenting with our
business model so we really have a
highly dynamic blueprint the business
model gives us some structure and
discipline to guide us through this
dynamic process so that the venture will
not come unglued when we think about
structuring the business model I believe
that the most important rule really it's
the rule for structuring anything is
that you need to break what you're
looking at they to no more than three
components and of course under each of
the components you may have some sub
structure but you really need to stop
with no more than three if you have more
than three components you don't have a
structure using the mass and you need to
rethink what you're doing in the case of
a business models let's see what are the
three struck the three components that
we are talking about the first component
is the so the three components or the
value creation model the profit model in
the logic of the business and the first
component is the value creation model
which describes how the venture creates
and delivers value to its customers and
that includes the product the target
customers value proposition where the
venture is position
within the value chain and distribution
since the product typically needs to be
delivered as well once we have created
some value we can extract some of it for
the venture itself and that's described
by the profit model that starts from a
revenue model that shows how we extract
revenue given the value to have created
in what is the cost structure of the
venture where we then focus on the
drivers of profitability for the venture
third component of of a business model
is what I call the logic of the business
the logic of the business is a
structured explanation that shows why
the venture is going to work how can we
actually create value and extract some
of it for ourselves
and typically we we want to structure it
as a flywheel that shows how the venture
it grows and becomes increasingly more
profitable in what I'm going to do next
it's kind of turn to Howard and a Howard
can you please tell us how you evaluate
a business model is a venture capitalist
sure every day I see five or six
different presentations of entrepreneurs
who are starting new businesses and
there are things that I think are not
interesting and there's things that I
think that are interesting in the
business model so first I'd like to talk
about the things that are not
interesting
the venture investors job is in the end
to make money as a result of the
business that they invest in being worth
a lot of money so one of the things that
is not interesting to me in a business
model is a company that's simply going
to take a lot of money to figure out if
they are viable profitable and able to
grow and that's that simply if it takes
a lot of money and you only make a
certain amount it's not a great
investment but if it takes a small
amount of money then it can be a great
investment another thing that's not
interesting to me is many participants
in the business model that means the
company has to rely on all sorts of outs
vendors or partners or companies or
technology integrators complexity is is
a horrible piece to a business model
there are there are some companies who
have figured out over time how a very
complex business model can work for them
but in general it's something that's
very concerning if you think about
Google it actually has a very very
simple business model which is making
money off of clicks for advertising all
the other things they do I think are sub
parts of their business model but that's
when it gets too complex it gets too
risky similarly a business model that
has many participants in the market is
not a great idea because it means it's
crowded and you have to fight and you
have to differentiate yourself in a very
complicated market with many players
which drives up your costs of customer
acquisition and penetrating the market
business models that require a lot of
integration with legacy systems tend to
be very slow a potential customer may
want to may want to purchase the product
but it just takes a lot of time and
money to make the decision to do it and
actually implement it so it's something
that slows down the business and is
harmful to a business model businesses
that are hit driven are not interesting
good example are gaming companies you
can have some very exciting games but if
your next one is not a hit your business
can drop in value and your business
model can dry up and go away as your
customers go to another another
competitor long sales cycle similarly
cost a lot of money and it takes a lot
of time to figure out if your customers
are going to buy from you and you know
meanwhile before you're profitable
you're burning a lot of money to get
there so it's not a great business model
and finally business models in the end
you're building a business to make a lot
of money and if your goal is to sell the
company or go public you need to
consider whether the market values your
business model or not a good example is
a high margin technology business with a
lot of customers that are cheap to
acquire can be worth a lot of money but
a service provider model where you're
doing consulting work is not valued a
lot
by the market so it's not as attractive
a business on the interesting side most
of these are just the counter part of
what I said in what aren't interesting
so capital efficient means you can
figure out if the business is going to
have a strong business model or not
without having to spend too much money
to figure that out something that is
quick we all only have so much time in
our lives we don't want to spend five or
ten years to figure out if a business
model is valuable or not we'd like to do
it in two or three or four years
complexity is bad so simple is good if
you can easily understand the business
model and describe it to someone you
have a great advantage over complexity
in the model being able to decide on
your business model and do things
independently without having to worry
about what other companies are doing or
that they are helping you out in your
process makes it for a much more
interesting business model again for a
customer is easy to understand the model
and adopt it businesses that have high
margin which means you make a lot of
money in the process
and finally I'm very attracted to
business models that the lifetime value
divided by the customer acquisition cost
is a compelling ratio and you get there
very quickly so you don't have to invest
a lot of money and take a long time to
get that money back hey Howard how did
Skype fit into that framework well Skype
with an interesting business because it
it upset inexpensive and slow industry
the telcos who had huge infrastructure
costs and it was impossible for them to
react I recall the CEO of AT&T
publicly stating a few months after
Skype had lunged that people consumers
are not willing to talk into their
computers and software is not a business
model and I think he was proven wrong
they provided in their business models
providing a software solution to a
traditional hardware model which was a
very inexpensive and fast thing to do
their customer acquisition cost was very
low and the cost because it was a
peer-to-peer model
was zero it cost them nothing to operate
the network so they could give it away
and as you can imagine a traditional
telco could do nothing about this
because it costs them a lot of money to
run their network and so they have to
charge people for it skypes model was
interesting in that because it was free
and they could give it away they decided
to make money only on things that cost
them some money to do it and finally
customer acquisition cost when I say it
was Oh point zero zero 1 of $1.00 that
was what we estimated the cost of
bandwidth and a download at the time
this was a viral model not in people
recommended to their friends but people
said to their friends this is how I'm
communicating now and if you ever want
to talk to me again you will download
this software so I had a very
inexpensive customer acquisition model
in addition the network effects that
were applied to this the more consumers
who used the business the more valuable
the network became and therefore it
became impossible for competitors to
break in even Google tried and spent a
lot of money but they were too late how
are what types of business models do you
like these days well first I just wanted
to give a little bit more Skype data
just real quickly to give a sense for
how the data fits into the business
model we just described they built and
launched their business on less than
$500,000 which means they were able to
build launch and get data in the market
on very low amount of money and then
they raised money while they were
already growing and they had some market
traction their revenue growth was very
quick when they turned on revenue
acquisition which was in selling
connection to the phone networks the
revenue model grew very fast from 5
million to 50 million 250 million
dollars they didn't require any outside
assistance they didn't require Facebook
they didn't require any partners they
did everything on their own so they kind
of wrote their own destiny and finally
they had a very interesting market
launch model which was the founders of
Skype
had founded Kazaa which was the largest
and most downloaded peer-to-peer music
sharing platform and they were the
founders of the company were sort of
heroes and killing the going after the
Recording Industry Association which was
charging for music and their business
model was to launch Skype that become
the bad boys of the internet now they
were going after the telcos and they
that was their plan and they promised me
that within a few months of launch they
would be on the covers of magazines and
newspapers as the bad boys of the net
and so I'm just going to show you here a
copy of this is a copy of Fortune
magazine just a few months after they
left after they launched the product
showing that they were the Pirates of
the net they bloodied the music business
with Kazan now they're going after the
300 billion dollar phone business this
these are not these guys are not pirates
this was all marketing for them this was
a plan in order to acquire consumers and
they did a great job great so way you
find any business models these days with
or is attractive is cut and there's you
know other than additional peer-to-peer
models that I'm seeing one area that's
quite interesting is 3d printing that
I've seen kind of growing lately cuz
it's causing many self-made
manufacturing at a unit level that I
think large manufacturers don't know how
to react to and there's going to be all
sorts of interesting problems around who
owns the content for how a product is
designed because the manufacturing where
the value used to be added is now being
removed from the equation another area
that I find extremely interesting is the
sharing economy getting so popular is
even making the cover of The Economist
lately and a big reason that I invested
other than the people and the business
and the business model the sharing
economy is providing a new business
model using existing assets and so I
would like to let Andre go from here
great Thank You Howard Thank You
professor Mendelsohn for inviting us
here I like to think about ourselves of
the Pirates of the car rental mobility
industries so let me talk to you little
bit about relay rights first of all
let's start with our vision we really
want to build the world's largest car
sharing and car rental fee repair
marketplace and our ambitions are to
build a marketplace with a huge network
of cars that provides comprehensive
geographic coverage with unique
selection of vehicles everything from
you know the smart card to the large
truck we want to offer amazing value for
renters so cheaper prices than what you
can find in traditional car rental car
sharing and enable owners to really
monetize an asset which as you all know
is it cost the asset to own and operate
and one that depreciates over time so
when I give owners the possibility to
actually start making money with their
vehicles and finally it's a marketplace
where that connects peoples we want to
make sure that we have a safe and
trustworthy environment for those people
to connect we disrupt many industries I
want to talk about three here that are
part of our scope first one is
traditional car sharing traditional car
sharing is a is the industry that is has
been made very popular by Zipcar in the
u.s. it's a 1 billion dollar industry
and what what traditional car sharing
does is they you know they acquire the
cars they manage the fleet they maintain
the fleet and they provide the rental
service and that's a billion-dollar
industry and by connecting people
directly neighbors in cities directly we
enable popular formats like hourly
rentals which really was the hallmark of
the traditional car sharing industry
that's a first market that we disrupt
and we want to be pirates in the second
market which is 30 times larger which is
the car rental industry that's a thirty
billion dollar in the US market 60
billion worldwide obviously much bigger
market much more established but very
very much same principle we're a large
corporation acquires a lot of
ours you know enterprise buys couple
million cars every year
Avis hurts by a couple million cars
every year and they maintain a suite of
in excess of 500 thousand cars in in the
US alone and what these guys offer is
again traditional car rental and we want
to disrupt that industry as well by
connecting people who have the car with
people who need the car to get that
rental directly without the intervention
of a large infrastructure provider and
then finally our our most ambitious I
would say vision over time is to disrupt
the US car ownership market which is a
1.3 trillion market we believe that by
getting tens of thousands of people to
share their car we can find ourselves in
situations five years from now where in
some of the largest cities in the US and
the world there could be so many cars
that are available for rent from people
around you maybe even in your own
neighborhood maybe on use on your street
maybe even in your condo that instead of
thinking of buying a car buying a second
car you might just as well you know use
that shared vehicle that is available to
you in such a convenient way and that's
a probably one of the largest if not the
largest industry it's the mobility
industry it's a 1.3 trillion industry in
the US alone and we believe that we you
know as as we're talking about earlier
in business models can work it's always
a timing issue you know it can be either
a bit too late or too early and we think
we're at the right time and one of the
reasons why we believe we're at the
right time is we're seeing real societal
changes when it comes to how people are
thinking about cars and the millennial
millennial generation is really thinking
quite differently about cars and the
that's one of the reasons why you know
we our model is actually very attractive
to some of the car manufacturers and
that's one of the reasons why we have a
interesting partnership with General
Motors almost all car manufacturers will
tell you that they're really concerned
about how the younger generation is no
longer buying cars and it's starting to
think about cars as a commodity rather
than as an aspiration in fact people
getting the driver's licenses much later
in life now than they used to 20 years
ago they socialized mostly through cell
phones technology I am you know social
media social networking and the sort of
mythical nature of the car and what it
used to stand for in society you know
for the previous generations it's sort
of going away and we can help accelerate
that trend by making super convenient
for people just share cars when they
need them so access instead of ownership
and we're part of you know the sharing
economy that that was alluded to I'm
sure you're familiar with many other
companies that are really
revolutionizing other large aspects of
the economy by connecting people through
platforms
it's very part of some of the brands
that we have here Airbnb TaskRabbit ran
the runway there literally tens and
hundreds of companies that are
disrupting everything from boat sharing
to bicycle sharing to mobility sharing
ride-sharing to fashion with men to
runway you know Airbnb is all about
foundation and travel and you know we
believe that software and the ability
that software has in connecting people
is going to disrupt a lot of those
established industries because our
business model is effectively much more
you know efficient and low-cost to
operate than building the infrastructure
that supports all these verticals so as
Haim talked about you know there's three
elements in the business model you know
my presentation is going to focus mostly
on the first element which is a value
creation for the consumer of the
audience and that's what we call in our
language sort of a value proposition so
let me explain to you a little bit the
value proposition for car owners and by
the way after the end of this
presentation I know there's 2,000 people
listening you should go out and rent
your cars and list them immediately on
reader eyes because you can you can get
the benefits of this value proposition
so as you can see in this presentation
here on this slide you know people are
doing it because it just makes sense you
know
economically an average car on relay
rides is four to five years old the
average owner rents it out seven to
eight days a month and makes a
$150 a month which is actually the cost
of maintaining that car so that's a you
know the first time I think in history
where you can own a car use it the vast
majority of the time two-thirds of the
time to record at a time and and find a
way to make the car not cost you
anything that that's a very powerful
value proposition and that's where the
average owner what we're finding is that
you know some of the owners are very
entrepreneurial and are becoming micro
fleet managers so they're you know
renting their car at you know almost
almost all the time or acquiring a
second or third car and some of these
owners are making thousands of dollars a
month and in fact you know I just showed
here in this presentation three of our
owners last year that made more with
really rights or enough with real rights
to actually cover the Kelley Blue Book
value of their vehicle or more and
they're buying their second and third
because they're realizing it's a little
profit that they can do and they're
quitting their jobs and doing it which
is a lot of fun that's one of the things
that so rewarding in the peer-to-peer
economy is you're you're not just
selling a service or a product to a
consumer that's buying you're also
empowering people to make money and to
do things that they couldn't do before
now on the renter side you know the
value proposition is very much the
traditional value property you expect
from a marketplace like eBay for example
where I spend 10 years and eBay has
built its business really based on the
next three elements first first one is
really value you know you can get stuff
on real arrives you can get stuff on
eBay you can get stuff on Airbnb etc at
a fraction of the cost where you that
you spend on other places traditional
places so the cost of a daily rental on
read' arises between twenty and forty
percent cheaper than competition and
when you're building a business that has
an inherent value advantage you're on to
something big
because people want to spend less money
if they can and of course that's one of
the reasons why we're so excited and
optimistic about the futures of this
business
the second element of the renter value
proposition is unique selection
this is just to show you some of the
diversity of cars and vehicles that's
available the marketplace and when you
think about the traditional model of car
rental or car sharing you know with the
big corporations buying you know lots of
cars to service the rental you know
these corporations are trying to get
economies of scale and they're
purchasing so they try to buy from one
manufacturer too they try to buy one
model or a few models in each cat just a
couple models in each category and they
try to buy lots of them so that they can
get the lowest possible purchase price
and as a result you know the car sleep
in these traditional currentl companies
is kind of boring you know it's mostly
you know cars that you know you wouldn't
necessarily want to buy for yourself
whereas in our marketplace you know
you've got everything and anything and
these are our owners cars so you've got
everything from you know hybrid cars
electric cars sports cars etc etc which
is even in 1965 Ford Econoline which is
fun you know fun to own these cars for
the weekend and and go on a trip
somewhere and finally and I alluded to
this earlier you know we are really
building a network and network that we
think can really trump the geographic
penetration of any other network that is
providing car rental so we're not only
going to be in places where there's
people we're going to be in places where
there's people activity and less people
less activity we have now cars across
all 50 states only 12 months after our
launch which is a remarkable
accomplishment this actually this slide
little bit old so we our last two states
where North Dakota and Montana and we
have no cars and both of these two
states and transactions do and we have
customers across 1200 cities and we
believe that by the end of 2015 we'll
have a car within a ten minute walking
distance 200 million Americans which
will be the most dense Geographic
Network for any car rental company and
we of course believe that that will
provide convenience to renter so value
selection and convenience this is sort
of the triumvirate
of the value prop for our renders great
thank you very much Andre a Howard when
you first saw the pitch for really rides
what did you think about its business
model the thing that the things that I
thought were interesting and the things
I thought were challenging I'll outline
both of them so on the interesting side
if this works when this works it can
generate a lot of money and that is the
most important thing in any business
model is revenue and profit and like
some like Skype where I described that
it was upsetting some incumbents with a
new model really rides is doing the same
thing as Andre commented about people
don't use their cars very much in fact
in the u.s. it's roughly eight person
you use your own car roughly eight
percent of the time which means 92
percent of the time you have a
depreciating asset sitting on the street
doing nothing and when you compare a
relay rides business model to a versus
business model or enterprises business
model they have more zip cars for that
matter they have to acquire vehicles
they have to manage them they have to
cover parking they have to cover all of
the expenses related to it and they have
to rent their car roughly 50 or 60
percent of the time just to break even
on a per car basis so those companies
have to be very careful how they expand
because it costs them a lot of money and
if they make a mistake in expansion they
lose a lot of money and the most
interesting part of relay rides business
model to me is that the most expensive
part the inventory is being borne by our
consumers in the network they are
providing an asset that they are under
utilizing and we are helping them take
advantage of that in making a small cut
as part of the process in terms of what
are challenging about this business
model I did comment that one thing
that's not so interesting is having to
rely on other parties in the process and
one of the areas in this business model
where we
must work with other parties as an
insurance this business requires due to
our wonderful American legal system that
we are very careful about what types of
coverage and protection we provide for
the drivers for the owners and for the
vehicles and so we have done a wonderful
job Andre and his team has done a
wonderful job in partnering with some
large insurance companies and doing some
own things in terms of trust and safety
and screening drivers to make sure that
they are good drivers all the things
that are necessary to make this work at
the point of investing in the company I
think that was still a big unknown I
think it has now been solved they've
done a great job and we understand it
but it was one of those areas which was
relying on another significant party if
we had not been able to acquire
appropriate insurance this business
would not have been able to move forward
so in this case they did and it is
moving forward and we're very happy with
that but that was a risk in the business
model great thank you very much another
partnership that took place last year is
the partnership with GM where you
integrated a OnStar to your own platform
the angra can you tell us a little bit
about the role of that partnership in
the development of the business model we
love connecting people and getting them
as efficiently and as easily as possible
to rent their car to other people and
one of the you know one of the issues
that we sometimes need to deal with is
people are willing to rent their
vehicles they love the fact that there
is renters neighbors around them that
they want to you know get their vehicles
to but sometimes they might be traveling
they might be at the office when the car
is at home or the car might be the
office and they may be at home and
there's these issues that prevent people
from you know being able to fill so we
call it fulfilling the transaction so
exchanging the keys and making sure that
the renter can get into the vehicle so
the team has been thinking about how can
we use technology to make this easier
and to you know use the marketplace the
bathrooms to connect people and also use
more technology to be able to fulfill
the reservation without having to
the owner meets the renter in person and
exchange the keys and that's where
OnStar really plays an important role as
you probably know OnStar has been
building automotive platform
technologies for the last twenty years
and one of the things we discovered as
we started talking to them if they had
you know tens of millions of vehicles
that are equipped with OnStar around the
country and all these vehicles can be
through the addition of some software
and through some smart integration of
our own application with their operating
system we can actually turn all of these
OnStar vehicles into rental vehicles
because you can actually control them
with the web and so this is a I think
the very first and I would say the most
ambitious experiment of really turning a
car into an internet device a true
internet device it's connected that is
connected to the web and also controlled
by the web this is not about putting
Pandora in your car or putting you know
Facebook on your car it's really about
having somebody from outside the car be
able to control the vehicle as if it was
an Internet device and so we love the
idea of innovating and experimenting
with OnStar to enable people to list
their vehicles in a couple clicks we
have all the data from OnStar so the
listing process is even easier than what
it would be and then for renters to be
able to rent the vehicle and then when
their plan comes to be able to get into
the vehicle then you can use our mobile
app they can use text messaging they can
use our website to just click the button
that says unlock the car and then
through the integration of our apps with
OnStar you know magically you know 15
seconds later the car unlocks and we
love this idea of working with car
manufacturers to really enable cars to
do things that they couldn't do before
because of that software integration and
we are I think in the very beginning of
that kind of integration of software
into vehicles great thank you very much
and let me end with a question to Howard
a we talked about to the logic of this
business and the idea that a
as the density and the number of owners
and renters on the system increases we
will have the more than hundred million
Americans who are within less than 10
minutes of the relay rights car so once
that happens Howard what do you think
will be the structure of the car rental
industry in the United States unless as
evidence with General Motors being
excited to work with relay rides I think
we will see a variety of auto
manufacturers working directly to be
part of the network what we'll have is
and the reason why this business I think
has so much potential to be worth a lot
of money was Andre describing disrupting
the car ownership model currently if you
need a car and you don't own one you
have to go to a rental agency which is
far away you may even have to get
somebody to drive you there when we hit
the goal of having a car within 10
minutes of where you live you don't need
to own your own car anymore and this
will be real a rice will be the platform
which makes it possible for you to use
relay rides as a car ownership
alternative as such the the large auto
manufacturers will as GM has be applying
their technology to the vehicles to make
sure that they are doing the best job to
satisfy these consumers as an example if
you want to rent a Chevy pickup truck
and there's one that's close to you then
relay rides is the right thing to use if
you want to rent a outtie sports car
they will as their technology advances
be putting the ability for people on
relay rides to to consumers on relay
rides to use that car as well and no
longer will it be one car one owner and
will you be sort of have to make the
decision what type of car you want to
own for the next five years instead you
will have a mix of different vehicles
pickup truck when you have some moving
to do a sports car when you want to take
your girlfriend on a weekend drive or a
SUV when you want to go skiing for the
weekend
so rather than being tied to one vehicle
you'll have the opportunity to be tied
to as many vehicles as are on this on
the system near your near your home that
are convenient for you and I think it
may result in more unique automobiles in
the future as instead of a large
manufacturer competing I'm just having
another Ford four-door sedan that may
not be all that differentiated we may
see even more differentiated vehicles
moving forward as they're vying for the
consumers who want to have unique
vehicles so when Andre and Howard
ascribe the business model we focused on
the value creation model and we talked a
bit about the logic of the business a
quite a number of questions have focused
really on the profit model starting from
the revenue models so how does real a
ride and Ray kind of create revenue yes
I saw the question there a great
question so let me answer in a couple of
minutes and because you can talk about
that for hours so from a revenue
standpoint you know we are a
transactional marketplace so we charge
the owners and the renters a fee in
owner the owners are charged 25 percent
for every rental they make so if you
make a rental of 100 bucks
which is the average transaction size
you know your net earnings as an owner
seventy five dollars and we keep
twenty-five dollars and then we charge
the renters a 10% fee on top of that so
we've got roughly you know a thirty five
percent take rate from from every
transaction and then we have the renters
pay for the level of insurance and
protection that they would like and we
have three levels of insurance and
protection we call them premium basic
and decline so based on your risk
profile or based on whatever coverage
that you might have from your car policy
or from your credit card you might
choose to select either premium or basic
or the client coverage so that's roughly
the
revenue models so expect between a 35
and a 40% take rate on every transaction
that's taking place through the
marketplace and that's pretty much the
type of take rates that little bit
higher than the take rates that you teen
traditional marketplace models you know
eBay for example where I spend ten years
between even PayPal charges fifteen
percent of transactions Amazon
Marketplace charges fifteen percent of
transactions Airbnb charges roughly
fifty percent of transactions the
reasons why we need to charge more we
get to that thirty five percent is
because of the insurance aspect that is
an important cost element we provide
owners and renters with liability
coverage as well as physical damage
coverage and that cost is an incremental
cost that you know doesn't affect for
example an e-commerce marketplace and
that's why our revenue take rates is
higher than traditional marketplaces at
thirty five percent now going deeper
into the profit model you know the key
costs for as the key variable costs for
us are insurance again and customer
service you know we are in the business
of connecting people around car rental
and a lot of things can require some
support from a customer service agent
whether it's changing their reservation
or having some issue with their trip or
having some needs for immediate support
in case there's an accident so this is
not a pure software model where you know
customer service is a very tiny part of
the equation our model is a marketplace
model so we have an important element to
consider which is the need for our
community to get support so we offer
phone support we offer email support and
that's a the second big part of our
variable costs and then the you know the
traditional you know fixed costs are the
ones that you'd expect which is building
technology hiring people you know
spending money on marketing spending
money on you know the staffs salaries
the benefits those are what you'd expect
in any company I won't spend too much
time talking about those because those
are pretty much familiar with any other
you know technology or any kind of
business
in a number of people's questions that
have focused on a two related issues one
is have you seen these types of models
share incoming mark economy models work
in other areas and people have asked
about the what I call the issue of trust
so of course we've seen a sharing
economy models in many many different
applications
some of them include toys apparel DVDs
anything you can think of people are
beginning to share in all of this raises
the question of how do you trust the
counterparty in the case of a renting
space as an Airbnb how how does the rent
that the person who rents out the repair
apartment how can they trust person the
other side in the case of relay rides of
course how can the person who owns the
car trust the person on the other side
what happens when there's an accident
how do we manage this network of trust
and that's one of the most interesting
aspects of these models in what I'm
going to do is ask Howard to kind of
describe to us how Trust works in a in
those a sharing economy models so the
most important piece of trust for
sharing economy models is reputation and
the more data that you have on both
parties whether they're on time whether
they don't whether they keep the car
clean whether they do what they say that
they're going to do the the trust that
we get is predominately built by
reputation over time but one of the
great things about having a reputation
model is the stronger it gets the harder
it is for competitors to come into the
model and compete with it
relay rides actually has a better
advantage over most starting out which
is we screen the drivers of the cars
very carefully to understand their
driving history and their driving
experience so that at the very least
we are bringing in drivers who we have a
good sense that they're trustworthy in
their in their history and experience
and there's a lot of data out there to
make this possible and then as we go
over time you reputation ratings will be
the thing that drives the most value and
helps to block out competitors in the
business if you look at a company like
eBay where I've been an active seller on
eBay for ten years my reputation is
extremely valuable to me I will make
sure that every transaction that I
perform I get rated as positive because
I can sell for higher prices and faster
if my reputation is better and I do a
good job with customer service
similarly in any of these models whether
it's Airbnb or relay rides or eBay on
both sides of the equation if you want
to be continued to have access to that
marketplace you have to do a great job
and build your reputation in each
transaction that you do may I add just
one additional perspective which is that
you wouldn't create a marketplace
business if you did not believe that
people are basically good and the
reality is you know
the vast majority people are great
people and the great news is the
emergence of all these marketplace
models and the sharing economy models is
a statistical proof of that because
there's people are not 99.9 percent good
those models would fall apart very
quickly and of course you know the
granddaddy of all of those is eBay so
you've got to start with a belief that
actually you know as an entrepreneur do
you believe that people are basically
good and if you don't don't get into the
market base model because you're going
to find every setback or every issue to
be really insurmountable so there's
always you know there's always bad
things can happen of course so you don't
want to be naive about thinking that
everything is going to work out really
perfectly every time and the job of a
marketplace manager which is how we view
ourselves a treaty rights is to make
sure that those things that
to happen can happen the least
frequently possible and that they're
really well taken care of when they do
happen and so the way we do that is by
screening these drivers as Howard was
talking about by using social
integration so that people can feel that
trust we call it trust and safety trust
is the visible component that makes you
feel good about you know transacting
with somebody and safety is the Hardcore
component behind the scenes using
metrics using screening using technology
to weed out the bad people before we
continue I just want to quickly thank
everybody for submitting all their
questions we've received a lot of
questions and unfortunately we're not
going to be able to answer them all but
again we want to thank you and first
linear questions okay so we have we have
a number of questions that focus on
matrix and unit economics where a in the
case of relay rides one can think of
unit economics is looking at a either
one renter or one owner in thinking
about the customer acquisition cost
versus the lifetime value of that
customer which is the net present value
of all of the money that we can get from
that customer after subtracting variable
cost over the time that they're staying
with us so what I'll do is aggregate a
couple of these questions and have one
question for under a related question
for Howard in Android what kind of
metrics do you track a to kind of
identify unit economics in through
Howard when you evaluate a business
model which metrics do you look at and
at what stage should people have those
metrics available for you great
questions you know we're one of the very
important capabilities that you need to
build when you're managing marketplace
kind of really be good at metrics very
good and it's one of the first people
that I hired when I join the company
couple years ago is a VI guy you know
business intelligence or analytics
and we look at a tons of metrics so we
let me summarize because we can talk
about that forever but we look at a lot
of supply metrics and demand metrics and
then transaction metrics so the supply
side will look at everything from
traffic to conversion of new owners then
owners first owners getting actual first
rental request then fulfilling these
requests we look at their transaction
value how much they're you know to your
point about like lifetime value will can
last and value for every owner so how
much money have they generate how much
gross margin how they generated on the
renter side we do the same thing look at
traffic we look at sign ups on the
renter side we look at conversion from
those sign ups into rental requests and
into completed rentals and repeat
rentals the goal is really to build that
LTV model so that we can understand
what's the value of a sign up what's the
value of the listing and then we can
orient our marketing strategy and our
spend and optimize our marketing
strategy on our spend in a way that we
never spend more than what the actual
lifetime value of a renter is or of an
owner could be so we look at all of that
and from a very metrics oriented way we
also then look at a lot of trust and
safety metrics I was talking about trust
and safety earlier so what percentage of
transactions result into a claim what's
the nature of these claims how can we
anticipate by building and enhancing our
risk management models how can we
anticipate with a little data anticipate
this could be a higher risk customer and
be able to put in some more safeguards
in place before we have that customer
either listener car or random car so we
do a lot of metrics a lot of modeling on
the risk management model of the
business and then finally we look at a
lot of metrics regarding customer
satisfaction you know - because we
believe things like NPS could be great
predictors of you know repeat usage and
of you know increased value of every
customer so those are the three large
buckets of metrics that we look into and
some of the metrics that Andre shared in
his presentation today such as the
average owner making a couple hundred
dollars a month and some owners making
all
for $1,000 a month some other data he
didn't share we have some cars that have
been rented hundreds of times individual
cars and some of those rental some of
them are the same renters renting them
over and over and over again once or
twice a week for six months and so what
we do in the young company is we build a
model that we think will work out and of
course when you start everything isn't
always working perfectly but you drive
towards a model and you measure things
and you say what is it about that owner
that that's causing him to make $1500
where somebody else is only making $200
and we evaluated and we try and make
other owners understand and do the same
things that owner is doing likewise why
are some renters what are the profiles
of demographics the Geographics the use
cases in a young company like this we
have a model for how it works and we are
driving some of the metrics are already
well within the parameters we need and
we continue to improve improve them and
others when we move into a new city and
we are getting cars in North Dakota but
we don't have a lot of renter's there we
know that there are some costs that are
necessary upfront to do it
but in the end all the answers aren't
there in any company ever and they're
always working to use the metrics and
trying things to get data to improve
over time and that is the stage that
relay rides is in right now and we are
quite pleased with the progress that we
are making